car tester Montez Kurata is driving a
vehicle that's hard to overlook or to
categorize the mercedes-benz vks from a
distance it looks like a transporter but
Daimler's transporter DeVito has little
in common with this vehicle so what kind
of a car is the V luxury track mobile
conference room office the V 250 D is
many things it's impressive and
comfortable to drive representative
orange
zebra cream chiffon the car were testing
is the new top of the V class line it
boasts a powerful 140 kilowatt engine
and a lavishly appointed interior
[Applause]
indexed Marcuse's the exclusive package
of the addition special model has just
about everything that's available for
the V class fine leather a decorative
seam on the dashboard it's exquisite
there's even air-conditioning for the
seats there are six or eight seats by
the way another distinctive feature is
these glass panorama sunroof that slides
open at the push of a button too bad
that the driver and front-passenger
don't benefit from this feature the car
has the sort of agile handling that
you'd expect from a V class model its
5.14 metres long and as a turning radius
of eleven point eight meters which is
very tight but Martha's points out that
those numbers only apply to the
rear-wheel drive model the V class is
also available with the 4matic all-wheel
drive and it's turning radius is notably
greater with a height of 1.9 meters in a
width of more than 2 meters the V class
is anything but decoratively dainty the
swept grille an ornate front skirt can't
change that but the V 250 D doesn't look
clunky especially with the optional AMG
styling package which includes a slide
rocker panel a revised rear bumper and
on top a roof edge spoiler too bad the
styling stops where people can't see it
the hinges of the electric hatchback
could have been designed more
attractively
the panorama sunroof gives the car a
special feel and when it's open it lets
in plenty of fresh air the optional
table is quite practical it can be
shifted around and folded out you can
also order rear seat drink holders the
seats can't be swiveled like in some
competing models but they can't be
clipped in to face forward or backward
or for more space that can be removed
the exclusive equipment package comes
with a middle console you don't really
need it but it does offer are useful 220
volt electric socket
[Music]
the manufacturer claims fuel consumption
is just six liters of diesel for 100
kilometers but we needed three more with
a car that weighs 2.5 tons and has a
maximum weight of more than three tons
that's hardly surprising compared with
other vehicles that have far less
utility value this is acceptable overall
our tester really likes this vehicle
[Music]
this monthís says the V 250 D has just
about everything you could want
including air conditioning and heating
for the seats adaptive cruise control an
optional lane departure warning system
and Blind Spot Assist in the mirrors
everything is electrically powered
including the left and right sliding
doors and the hatchback Mathis is
pleased with the overall package he
calls it a very elegant vehicle that has
a use value it can be configured to
provide a mix of passenger seats and
cargo space Montes is very impressed
with this V class car finish - I was
positive and gotten from these are four
classic
[Music]